monopolies don't last
1904 Rockefeller Standard Oil controls
at 91 of the U.S oil Market
2004 Standard Oil is just something that
we read about in the history books
2000 GE becomes the world's largest
company
2021 GE announces that they'll be
divesting it into three different
companies 2007
Nokia is synonymous with cell phones
2023 Nokia is the Legacy company that's
iconic for its ringtone 2015 Apple
Google Amazon and meta rule the world
but 2045 2060 when is their expiration
these companies it may seem Unstoppable
unbreakable today but there's only one
thing for certain each and every one of
these companies will fail in fact the
bigger they get the faster they'll fall
you're probably asking how I mean no
one's ever gonna stop using smartphones
or the internet right well that's just
because we don't yet know what's next
Henry Ford once famously said if I had
asked people what they wanted they would
have said Faster Horses today
horse-drawn carriages are virtually
obsolete so here's why all monopolies
are doomed to fail and why big Tech has
already started their demise
foreign
people love to hate on monopolies but
they often forget that it wasn't that
long ago that the very same companies
were cherished you see companies don't
just randomly become monopolies because
they had a better marketing or something
companies become monopolies because they
offered something that was undeniably
better than everything else Standard Oil
offered an undeniably better way for
energy production and transportation ATT
offered an undeniably better way to
communicate and modern tech companies
started off by offering an undeniably
better way to navigate the internet
Amazon mastered online shopping Apple
mastered handheld devices Google
mastered advertising and at Facebook
mastered online communication so
ironically the first stage of a monopoly
is actually love all monopolies were
loved by most of its user base at some
point in time that's how they became a
monopoly but this love also gives
companies a lot of control allowing them
to do things that normal companies
wouldn't be able to get away with Apple
for example was able to drop the
headphone jack prevent consumers from
repairing their devices and even remove
the power brick yet there's still the
biggest company in the world because
people love iPhones such anti-consumer
moves are usually what raise the first
red flags that a given company is
actually just a monopoly but by this
point the company already has control
over the market and they shift their
focus to building an empire during this
stage companies can basically throw out
anything they want and it'll stick
likely the best example of this was
Microsoft back in the 90s and 2000s
windows and office were actually
phenomenal products that people loved
Internet Explorer on the other hand was
not but that didn't matter because
Microsoft was able to push IE using
Windows the same thing could be said
about Hotmail Outlook and the MSN Suite
of products the same thing can also be
said about Google and apple throughout
the 2010s people started using Google
drive because they already had Gmail
account people started using Google
photos because they were already using
Android similarly with apple people
started using iCloud Apple music Safari
and Apple Maps because it came along
with iPhones this isn't to say that
these products were bad but they weren't
especially a stellar either I mean let's
just be honest who's gonna use Apple
Maps or Safari or the Apple mail client
if it wasn't for iPhones
the answer is no one and this is really
the trademark of an aged Monopoly people
use their newest products not because
they were extraordinary but because they
were associated with something that was
extraordinary piggybacking mediocre
Products off of extraordinary products
only works for so long though
[Music]
the beginning of the end for most
monopolies is actually just themselves
as monopolies grow more powerful we
start to see a clear disconnect between
the company's original purpose and
vision and the goals and visions of the
company's employees I mean just think
about it what type of person joins a
monopoly
well it's usually someone with the
mindset of if you can't beat them you
might as well join them and I don't
blame these people whatsoever they're
simply looking out for themselves as
they should be but this doesn't exactly
play out well for the organization
suddenly the primary goal of the average
employee is no longer to serve the
customer in the best way possible in
fact the average employee might not even
know how their role impacts the customer
as there simply so many layers between
them and the final product so the
primary goal of employees transitions to
impressing their managers getting
promotions and scoring bonuses this is
how it becomes across the entire
corporate ladder and as for the top well
the top isn't any better most of the
visionnaire executives have likely
already retired moved on to something
else or have just passed away so the
people who are left aren't Visionaries
they're the ones who are able to play
the corporate game the best they were
able to handle office politics and the
backstabbing and crappy managers and
ineffective teams and whatever else
these people aren't exactly leaders a
better description in would be Survivor
similar to winning The Hunger Games or
something and given that this is what
they've been used to their entire career
as Executives they're gonna focus on
Survival how do they survive at the top
well it's not by serving the customers
it's by serving the shareholders the top
two things that shareholders are looking
for is growth and profit and thus the
priorities of the company also becomes
growth and profit what's the easiest way
to do this well the easiest ways are to
cut costs and increase prices a perfect
example of this is Google with Larry
Page and Sergey Brin at the helm the
focus of the company was to push the
boundaries and experiment in fact Google
was always super proud of all their
failures of which they had hundreds
their philosophy was always you're gonna
have a bunch of failures if you want to
succeed but I'm not sure if we can say
the same thing about sundar's Google
over the past several months itself
Google has been pulling back on moonshot
ideas so substantially in fact in some
areas they have canceled as many as half
of their projects it's easy to say that
they're pulling back because of the
recession but it's not like Google or
Facebook or really any big tech company
that's doing layoffs or actually at risk
they're not even remotely close to being
unprofitable for Giants recessions are
simply a time to maximize efficiency so
that they can become even more
profitable for the next Bull Run but by
the time the desire to maximize
short-term profits becomes larger than
the desire to create a long-term change
the end is already near
Monopoly is really quite a fitting name
for these companies because most modern
monopolies are dependent on just one
product it might seem like they're
everywhere with hundreds of products and
services but really the base of the
company can usually be traced back to
just one product to this day Google
search accounts for over 50 percent of
all of Google's revenue iPhone's account
for over 50 of all of Apple's Revenue
AWS is the only reason that Amazon is
even profitable and the entire business
of meta can be summed up by Facebook
WhatsApp and Instagram the only Tech
Giant that breaks this trend is
Microsoft they've become more of a tech
holding company than an actual business
which seems to be working out great so
far but we'll have to see how it plays
out over the long term as for everyone
else though their Empires are actually
extremely Fragile the reality is that
while they may have hundreds of
microservices that generate a bunch of
Revenue the only reason that any of
these services are successful is because
of the base product iCloud for example
has nearly a billion users but how many
people would stick around after the
iPhone is disrupted similarly how many
people would even know about the
metaverse if it wasn't for Facebook the
harsh reality is that the only reason
these extensions are successful or even
relevant is because of the success of
the original product once that Fades
away so does the entire company this
isn't to say that the company goes
bankrupt the day after or something
rather they become a shell of their
former self similar to IBM or atnt or GE
they might be everywhere but at the same
time they're nowhere because the brand
no longer carries the same weight take
chat GPT for example let's say chat gbt
replaces Google search which it might
very well do as the masses flock go over
to chat GPT people will naturally start
using the products that are associated
with chat GPT versus the products that
are associated with Google given that
Microsoft is a major investor in chat
GPT this means that a lot more people
will start using Edge Bing Outlook
OneDrive and Microsoft Office all of a
sudden Google's major product categories
of Chrome Gmail Google Drive and Google
office aren't nearly as popular despite
nothing changing about them the bottom
line is that the hero product changed
and with that all of the auxiliary
products also changed so most of these
big tech companies aren't as Invincible
as they may seem while they may have
hundreds or even thousands of popular
Services it's only a handful of products
that really drive people to the
ecosystem once those products fall out
of favor so does the entire company
looking at Fang today it's clear that
they're well past stage one of being a
monopoly the days of people loving them
were 15 to 20 years ago nowadays the
sentiment that dominates for Fang is
actually concerned concerns about their
power and influence concerns about
privacy concerns about anti-consumer
behavior these guys are also well past
stage two they've already leveraged
their market share to push other
products and services and to become
omnipresent their focus is no longer to
improve the world but to maximize stock
growth this is why they spend so much
money on stock BuyBacks Apple for
example has spent 573 billion dollars on
BuyBacks over the past 10 years I've
said this before but that's literally
enough money to buy out another Fortune
10 company such behavior is only evident
in a late Stage Company if this was 2007
Apple would have been way too busy with
scaling Manufacturing factoring
Logistics and r d to be spending half a
trillion on BuyBacks but all of this
brings up the question how much time do
these companies have left well for that
we can just take it from the horse's
mouth itself Jeff Bezos life's fans
Charlie and Amazon will be disrupted one
day then you worry about that I don't
worry about it because I know it's
inevitable companies come and go and the
companies that are the shiniest and most
important of any era you wait a few
decades and they're gone and your job is
to make sure that you delay that date
I'd sure I would love for it to be after
I'm dead
hearing that and looking around big tech
companies are rapidly approaching this
Milestone Amazon is 29 years old Google
is 25 years old and Facebook is 19 years
old now apple is 47 years old but they
were completely reinvented with the iPod
and iPhone so the modern apple is more
like 20 years old so it's likely that
the utter dominance of these companies
is already behind us in fact the peak
was probably the pandemic again this
isn't to say that these companies will
go bankrupt tomorrow but what this does
mean is that they've already started the
transition into becoming the ciscos and
in toes of the world and once they spend
a good amount of time there they'll
become these xeroxes and the Codex of
the world and that that is the
inevitable future of a Fang clearly
things aren't looking too great for big
Tech but likely the one exception is
Microsoft if you're wondering why check
out this video but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one